more historic flooding will ravage the
central us into the weekend seven
millions Americans are seven million
Americans rather are at risk from rising
rivers this morning Adriana Diaz is in
Grafton Illinois along the Missouri
border with more on this story Adriana
good morning good morning the situation
is dire here in Grafton the town built
this wall out of concrete and gravel to
protect Main Street but some water
already seeped through which is why they
have been pumping it out all night now
on this part of the wall in some areas
there are 10 feet of water and this
talent just can't catch a break this is
their fourth flood since October roughly
a hundred people have evacuated and
businesses that just rebuilt are ruined
again this is where the Mississippi and
Illinois rivers meet so heavy rain up
north and snowmelt created this rose
throughout Illinois are also fully
submerged in some areas and one of the
longest-running floods in the state's
history
several towns from Minnesota to Arkansas
have also been evacuated and to the
south a storm in the Gulf of Mexico
brought rain and flooding threats to
parts of Texas and Arkansas where the
water is already covering farmlands now
over the past few days the rain will
continue in areas near the Gulf but here
in the Midwest we do expect to dry up
the rivers are expected to crest as
early as tonight so the worst will be
over but the waters won't fully recede
until next month
Dana mother nature's wrath Adriana thank
you